[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are terrific
guest this week is a writer and the
author of the tribe when Cobb Lee
welcome to trigonometry it's so great to
have you here before we get into the
interview and we'll talk about the book
itself and some of your thoughts tell us
a little bit about how you are where you
are and how you've come to be sitting in
this chair well yes it's been quite a
long and strange journey in a way I mean
maybe roughly about 10 years ago I I
sort of stepped out to an extent you
know a normal sort of career I was a
business business journalist and you
know I wanted to I just had an itch that
I wanted to scratch really and I know
I'm kind of getting part-time in the
work and then exploring my own interests
so you know reading a lot including
really lot of philosophy literature
other stuff and around about the same
time I also thought I mean I'd spent all
my years basically since University
sitting in pubs moaning about politics
and knowing better and actually not
really doing anything so yeah so around
that time I thought like why not get in
and get your hands dirty so I mean I've
always been on the left since that since
University before that since school days
so I joined the Labour Party locally and
got myself involved so like I say this
was mainly about ten years ago
so through doing that I mean immediately
sort of joining and getting involved
both locally and on
or sort of national level you know just
writing blogs and sort of getting
involved in that kind of that fort world
I started why I saw very quickly how
identity politics was just was so strong
not just in the labour party but in the
wider left-wing movement so I started to
explore that and and started to write my
own blogs ran about you know 2011 for
labor blogs like I say and and for quite
a long time sort of was exploring that
through my writing while also reading a
lot of philosophy and other stuff
they're starting to work that into my
own you know into my own writing and
thoughts as time went on and you know
being in labor and being in that wider
left sort of world you know my my
critique of identity politics how you
know how I could see that was so
powerful but there were you know aspects
we should I'd not just disagree with I
thought were dangerous and bad so you
know I could see myself starting to pull
away well you know I've been quite
involved in the beginning and have
really quite enjoyed it too so you're a
passionate labor activist at this point
right well I mean passion is maybe and I
thought you know and getting involved in
a local party was a really good thing to
do you know to a new area it was a great
way to get to know that new area people
who had similar sort of interests but
yeah this sort of stuff was what really
interested me
[Music]
identity politics and what was the
response to some of your writing in
those days that's kind of 2011 2012 we
are talking about identity politics
within your world that you were in at
the time handed people I think people
tended to stay away from it ignore it
there was there was some very strong
aggressive response you know especially
from some feminists at that time I mean
I remember I had a one person sort of on
Twitter threatened to throw and
life in my face because I question the
idea of the patriarchy it's you know
it's it's funny and it's kind of
ridiculous it was also a bits genuinely
scary and and it's kind of an element of
the you know how powerful it was you
know that if you if you questioned it in
a non quite an honest way you know
people would really come after you and I
was I was attacked by you know verbally
by politics words of violence we know
you know and you still do you know it
kind of takes you aback and especially I
think more in the power aspect of like
you know if you say something out of
turn you know people do genuinely come
after you you know that's politics to me
you accept it but it's like if you do it
if you do this they come after you
so I mean eventually I mean it came to
call been getting elected and I mean I
knew you know quite a lot about his past
you know his links with Islamists and
other you know stuff that I disagree
with you know the anti-semitism is kind
of related to that so I was unhappy
about that so I was kind of aging away
from labor and on the edge of leaving
and then the bracelet thing have
happened and I I decided for breaks you
know I was quite narrowly full brace at
the beginning but again with that the
the response that you got personally but
also as a kind of group of bricks it
supporters even on the left was you know
really strong and I mean seeing Alan
Johnson the you know the XMB who's
leading the labour against breaks a
campaign you know when he came out and
said that brexit ears were extremists it
was kind of like this was the last straw
you know as well as being called a
racist and anti-immigrant and they
granted all the rest of it so at that
stage I left labor but with the book I'd
started writing the book I think in run
about February
2015 so I had already been working on it
for quite a while at that time so I mean
that's that's right I guess my
background is as much as I can think of
it now so you've left labor where are
you mentally politically now is there a
home for someone like you who maybe has
a kind of old-school leftist view of
certain things but doesn't buy into the
diversity and identity politics side of
things well there hasn't been but I
think it's quite interesting there are
there are things going on in you know
mostly underneath the surface at the
moment in politics so I mean I haven't I
mean even when I was in labour most the
time I I really felt I didn't really
belong there but I kept on because of
the local links because you know you've
got friends and you know you value those
relationships but but I mean now
organizationally there isn't that much
but there are a few things popping up
and you know I think with the with the
brexit thing has brought people together
and there are organisations forming and
you know existing ones which are kind of
building up a bit more so I think it's a
very interesting time when you were
mentioning about Korbin now I get a lot
of people talking about Korbin then
there's the links of anti-semitism and I
personally find it quite confusing
because people allude to them being an
anti-semite
is he an empty someone in your view and
actually what evidence is there for this
because it's quite serious allegations
it not that you have but a lot of people
labeling with it what do you think he is
and what evidence is there for him being
anti-semitic as it were I'd I would be
very careful about calling him
personally an anti-semite it's it's more
the people he's associated with and
events he's gone to where you know very
overtly anti-semitic stuff has been said
and yeah these are people he continues
to associate with and and event he he's
continued to go to so I mean it's it's
almost a guilt by
Asian thing we're finding and I mean
mixed into it as well of course is that
this is politics and people who opposed
to Corbin can leap onto the
anti-semitism Semitism accusation and
beat him with it but there's there is no
smoke without fire there is you know
there is a genuine association there
with a lot of anti-semitic people and
well in particular was there anybody
that you could actually pin something on
there was this or is it this group or
anything well I could say I'd you know
I'd be cautious about about doing that
and I mean with with the book and my own
research is it isn't something I got
really deep into yeah it's more like I
say the association's I'm glad you've
taken that approach actually because I'm
someone who's from a Jewish background
and I what I start to say no anymore
but the thing is like I'll I'll joke
about Jeremy Corbyn and anti-semitism on
stage because I think it's a stereotype
that's out there that's funny
but I would never allege that he is
anti-semitic because I've never met him
I don't know if he's anti-semitic and
what I resent most of all is Jews now
being encouraged to play the stupid
identity politics game from our end as
well you know it's like oh well there's
guilt by association maybe he went to
this event it's like well maybe did
maybe didn't you know we don't know and
until this hardcore evidence I think
it's much better to take your approach
which is to go we're gonna be very
careful about this and we're not gonna
make yes I mean I think it's it's coming
back some of this sorry I haven't
thought about lots of stuff in depth for
a while but it is coming back some of
the aspects you know which you can
actually pin on him and the classic one
for me that really turned my head was
when I saw the video of him you know
very overtly calling Hamas and Hezbollah
friends our friends
I don't know veins I think in
Westminister and he's invited you know
these people to Westminster
events now Hamas in its founding
documents you know has over the
anti-semitic statements you know it
talks about chasing Jews and killing
them and for me to to embrace Hamas on
that aspect and say they are your
friends I mean obviously it's a it's an
indirect Association yeah it's a strong
one I think I hear what you're saying
well what I mean is like if I think I
don't like jeremy corbyn's politics on
many things but if I look at him do I
think this is a hateful person that
hates Jews which is what anti-semitism I
don't think so or I don't know right
so I think all sides need to be really
careful about it's very easy like when
this story happened with me before
Christmas so many people were like look
talkin don't even talk about how you're
Jewish and how you're oppressed and what
no we don't we're not gonna play the
left the radical loony left side
identity politics came from our end
because it's stupid we're saying the
game is broken let's stop playing that
game do you know what I mean so I think
the stuff about Jeremy Corbyn has been
an Semitic it's funny to joke about as a
comedian but I really don't think we
should focus on it quite as much as we
have been Francis this is anyway let's
talk about your book because this is
what this is really about that the
subtitle of the book is the liberal left
and the system of diversity and in in
the preface to the book you talk very
carefully about how you you're you you
you say you're being critical of some of
these things but actually it's both
Francis and I read the book I think are
certainly my impression was that you're
not being critical you're describing it
as it is and unfortunately some of the
things that you're describing are the
way they are is so broken that it seems
like you're being critical when you're
actually describing so talk to us about
when you talk about the system of
diversity what do you really mean by
that well I mean in terms of it of
diversity being a system I mean it's a
form of politics you can say there's an
ideology of diversity out there but in
terms of a system I'm talking about that
there are relations there
you know which kind of work in a
systemic aspects you know so if I say
something on on social media for example
I accuse someone famous of being racist
or something it's like there there's a
ready audience for that sort of
statement so I can make a call out there
and I'll get a favorable response and
and they'll and it will gain a it's
likely to gain quite a favorable hearing
in you know the newspapers especially
you know the more well-known I am you
know I'm not going to gain publicity and
sympathy by saying that whether it's
true or not now so in terms of it being
a system it's like we can see
possibilities there for acting in in
certain ways which will you know benefit
us in and in different ways there's also
the aspect of course of
institutionalizing diversity which you
know through rules and laws so I mean
we've been seeing that a lot of a you
know past few years with the spread of
positive discrimination although it's
now redefined as a positive action I
think actually so the more its kind of
institutionalized the more sort of favor
you have towards certain identity groups
and others again that that creates more
possibilities you know for for getting
jobs or if you if you oppose this sort
of thing for losing your job or if you
have the wrong identity and you promote
that identity for example you know
myself yourselves as well as white males
if we promoted ourselves as white males
that wouldn't go down well and a lot of
our institutions that's why I talk about
Jewish of being Jewish all the time
smoking art in America yes but actually
it's funny because I always talk about
this like in Russia someone who looks
like me would be considered black
I had people when I was living in Russia
tell me go home you're black so the
identity thing is like I I've had it on
both ends I've been the white man though
a straight white man in this country and
I've also been the oppressed minority
and that's why I feel really strongly
about this stuff is because these are
all just labels really that's what they
are you know what I mean
like looking at someone and judging them
by what you think they are it's very
superficial way of living life I think
it is on one level and I agree with you
but you know as I worked on the book I
started to realize that you know there
is a real significance to it as much as
we give it significance so for example
you know the more identity you know the
more say female identity is politicized
in public life that also politicizes a
male identity especially if if that form
of identity politics is saying that men
are a bad thing you know talking about
the patriarchy or something that
automatically politicizes men and makes
it part makes being male a part of the
public sphere and you know in one way or
another we've we we have to address that
you know and we can address it by going
on it you know it shouldn't matter but
it does matter and you know that's
that's as far as I go yeah I mean but
isn't there a positive element to it
when it comes to diversity quotas where
it just does give other people who've
been underrepresented a voice I mean
there was one time at the BBC where it
just seemed to be unless you were white
middle class or actually let's be fair
upper-middle course when talks were
Cambridge you didn't really get to look
at so during the Christmas holidays I
went to a play called nain night which
was on at the West End which was on at
the National Theatre and it was by it
was the first play at the West End to be
to be have a black female playwrights
ever the first one we went to the plate
it was brilliant and what was great is
instead of going to the theatre and
being surrounded by people of one
demographic you looked out there were
mixed couples there there was diverse
and it actually
created a really vibrant interesting
experience yes I completely agree with
you and and even with you know if that
playwright for example was selected on
the basis of their race if they were a
good playwright you know and they
produce a good play so you know iki can
work well and and I've seen although I
think there's quite a few examples of it
out there I mean like I quite like how
you know for example women's football
and women's cricket has been directly
promoted you know and that's a form of
identity politics in the public sphere
and it's been it's been a big success I
think there are there are other examples
out there the the point where it comes
in to a critique is when you know the
people being promoted or not and are not
good or you know not up to stand over
them you're only selecting them on the
basis of you know their identity you
know their and then it can obviously get
us into trouble and just reduce the
quality of arts or you know sport that's
appearing in front of us
I think cetera but yeah I agree with you
you know it's not by oh by all means all
bad and I mean one thing in one of the
chapters I write about diversity itself
as a word you know there are different
interpretations of that I mean the
politics of diversity the ideology
always is actually different from the
meaning of the word diversity itself
which means literally you know variation
and difference well the politics of
diversity isn't really about variation
and differences is often about choosing
certain people over others in on the
basis of you know their skin color and
their gender etc it's interesting that
you say that because isn't there an
argument to be made so for instance if
somebody isn't as good let's say won't
let's say for instance a comedian just
plucking something out there but and
then not as good but don't worry you'll
get your change easily find it don't
worry about it but they see them on
like for instance on a panel shot like
for instance so for instance like a
black woman on a panel show and she she
might not be at the same level as
everybody else but a young black girl
could see Rondo actually I can do that
because I'm represented on this TV
program therefore that becomes for me
suddenly a career path that I can choose
and pursue whereas if that young black
girl saw an all white male panel she
might go instinctively or subconsciously
do you know what then that I'm not
represented there therefore I will not I
that is not a career path for me yes I
can see aspects of that which you know I
agree with you to an extent but the
further we go down that path of
identifying with our skin color the
further away or our gender or whatever
the further away we get from the idea of
being inspired by ideas and by quality
and by what someone is saying for
example I mean I I would say sort of my
ideal situation would be you know
someone watching that prorack program
sees someone whoever whatever color or
gender saying something that interests
them and being inspired by that and
almost you know their their demographic
is almost irrelevant I mean that's
that's the way I would see a kind of an
ideal sort of diverse society sort of
working and the more we go down or sort
of avenues of separate identities and
and you know that the you mean you must
be represented by people of of that
demographic I think you know there are
aspects that that's quite dangerous
because it's it's cordoning off you know
it's it's communal it ends up in
communal politics really and and I you
know I like the idea I mean the other
idea of diversity which is mixing and
difference and you know exchange going
on do you sometimes thing and I and I
think the BBC's per ticking guilty of
this in that I see I see some it be more
diverse which on the whole I think is a
positive thing but what I do not see a
lot of the time is a diversity of
opinion
so it's essentially people who look
different but they spout the same sort
of rhetoric or have the same political
opinions or viewpoints on the world hmm
I mean this is a sort of thing that I'm
talking about in the book and what I
mean by the system of diversity again is
I mean it's it's not all obviously what
you know people who appear on TV and
especially in the BBC there it's not all
obviously related to diversity and
identity politics but an awful lot of it
is and and what I write about it in in
in the book is another system of
diversity the fundamental relations
there between you know what we might
might call you know the liberal left as
I call it well the progressive liberal
left which is a really a group of people
who oversee society and you know so for
example if you work for the BBC you're
in a position where you can help oversee
you know what millions of people sort of
watch and hear every day so you've got a
very privileged position there and you
know people are conscious of that they
do you know quite rightly they see it as
a responsibility you know what they show
but the relation then in terms of
diversity politics and identity politics
is often that they're they're overseeing
society to cast favor on some identity
groups you know which as you say are
being traditionally maybe
underrepresented and look to represent
them more in a positive light and then
obviously with with the other groups
that means you know the unfavorite
groups I call them as they cast them in
a more negative light is sort of
oppressors and then the favor groups as
the oppressed so I don't know I forget
what the original point was and where so
diversity of opinion yeah I mean that's
that's a basic relation and it's a it's
a form of knowledge that this is how the
world works is that oppressor groups
oppress prep you know the oppressed
groups favored groups victimized the
favorite groups and so you see an awful
lot of that in our public sphere now and
if you you know if you look at the BBC
website you'll see a lot of stories
which are based around that sort of
relation of you know for example women
being victims of men and and stories
being told about that and I mean I don't
you know I'm not against those stories
being told at all you know if they're
real but it's it's any it's an
interesting thing that's come about more
over the years that that sort of reality
is promoted and placed in front of us a
lot more and situations which don't
reflect that reality do not so much get
put in in front of us you know when
we're watching them you know BBC news or
something like that I hope that wasn't
waffling I was gonna ask you do you
think there's a kind of intellectual
philosophical underpinning to this whole
thing because it strikes me increasingly
that this whole thing of social justice
and identity politics it's more like a
system of faith than it is a system of
thought in the sense that quite a lot of
the things that they talk about are not
factually based so take something like
the gender pay gap right this is
something we've explored plenty on the
show and we've had scientists and
experts come and tell us basically that
the gender pay gap there is some gender
pay gap but largely it's down to
people's choices and it's not down to
discrimination right but this is
completely counter to the mainstream
narrative that is being advanced the
whole time right and if you look at all
kinds of other areas whether it's racial
discrimination we've talked to many
rumors ahooo you know about how
complicated that picture actually is as
most of the thing that we're being fed
by the media all the time wherever you
look you start to see that they're
assertions about the way the world is
what you're talking about oppress has
oppressed the hierarchy of the
oppression Olympics etc it's not
actually based in fact right it's not
based on research it's not based on
science it's based on a kind of seeming
it seems to me and challenge me if you
don't agree kind of like you have to get
this faith
based assertion into your head and if
you don't then you must be
excommunicated then you're racist then
you're sexist then you're whatever
there's certainly that element to it I
mean I would I would describe it more as
ideological you know in that it's this
these forms of policy they they unite
knowledge and politics you know the
knowledge of oppression it automatically
follows that you should favor the groups
that oppress you know that makes basic
sense but that knowledge of oppression
is universal you know it's it's it's
society-wide so I mean I I draw a
distinction between example when we talk
about racism or sexism or whatever I
mean clearly exist but there's there's
real actual behavioral racism that
exists and then there's ideological
racism which which is a much broader
category and that's you get a signal
when you say ideological races and what
kind of thing are you talking about well
it's it's for example calling someone
racist you know if you if you if if they
want to if they advocate reduce the
immigration you know so you know in in
in the sort of way I write about it in
the book you know reduce immigration
would be reducing the increase of
favored groups you know immigrants you
know non-white people non-english
non-british people in the country so
that goes against the sort of the
politics of diversity and you know if
you're an anti-racist
yeah you naturally think well you can't
be easily led to think well if I'm if
I'm on this side as an anti-racist and I
favor immigration then you know someone
who who wants to put some limits on it
is automatically a racist it kind of
maybe I'm not explaining that well very
well but it all sort of seems to fit
again as a as a sort of system of belief
yeah so that you can have faith in and
you mentioned you know there's not so
much thought you know sort of
intellectual basis theory
that's it in a way what makes it so
powerful this forms of politics then you
can just get up every morning and you
can roll it out you don't have to really
do anything thinking about it you can
respond to situations as they arise on
that basis and it's easy that's great
absolutely I mean that's how you know
effective politics works and I you know
it's a big theme of a book and as I was
working towards you know actually
starting to write it and then write ears
kept on striking me how powerful this
politics is and and over time I start to
realize more and more it's largely
because it's just damn easy it's so
straightforward all you need to know is
that these these certain identity groups
are victimized and these are the ones
are oppressors and and from there almost
[Music]
politics is how it's all these norms in
this country and you know especially the
white working-class if you look at it in
terms of like I'm a former teacher so in
terms of achievement white working-class
boys on the bottom rung and it's a
problem right the way through education
and we're talked about you know and we
as teachers to sit down talk about how
to engage white British and all the rest
of it but it close has a major part to
play in this hmm what people say got you
know white men are the oppressors but if
you were born I used to teach in
Cornwall if you are a white male born in
a working-class part of Redruth for
example you don't have a lot of hope or
a lot of chance unless you're very very
lucky
mmm that's just a white privilege yeah
yes yeah no it's a and sorry I'm gonna
return to this whole system of diversity
thing of how that works because I mean
obviously that the working-class appears
to be kind of ignored
you know people talk about oh that the
left has left the working class behind I
don't think many many people that have
been intended necessarily to do that
although there's there's a definite
cultural distance there there's this
kind of basic lack of sympathy lack of
familiarity lack of knowledge which we
used to have back in the day of course
you know it's it's kind of almost going
back to a very full old form of class
politics I think but I think it's
happened largely by accident but yeah
going back to the system of diversity I
think you know that these new forms of
identity policies are very important in
this in what's happened to the working
class not the only important thing by
any means but it's been you know
especially white working-class people
but and it goes back I think to when I
talked about you know the overseeing
class for example of the progressive
liberal left in this book has become
more of a sort of template for for how
you know white people can get over their
privilege you know for example more
white men can get over there they're
multiple privilege is by favoring the
favored groups
now this me and Ally yes and and this
this naturally suits people who are
quite well-off quite comfortable you
know they can deal with that
they have some cushioning against
passing favor over to other people but
if you're working-class the idea of of
favoring a different group other than
your own and giving them special
protections and and favoritism when
especially if you're if you're competing
with say say poor immigrants you know in
in for housing and for jobs just
existentially that that's sort of that
idea I think is almost incomprehensible
you know if you're in that sort of
situation so I think these forms of
politics have resulted in a further
distancing you know cultural distancing
they're you know both on the
working-class side and also on you know
aggressive liberal left and the wider
middle-class I think you know I fight
really refreshing that you've raised
that point because what I've noticed and
particularly with doing comedy which is
very liberal left in inverted commas is
a contempt I have for working-class
people so I used to living in Croydon
and for those of you who don't know
coordinates the place go there if you're
visiting you want to die over there
right so I used to live in Croydon my
flatmate was a mixed-race plumber and he
was a you kid photo and I'm mixed-race
electrician sorry he was a uke it's all
the same yeah and I sat down I don't get
why you vote for you Kip you know your
mixed-race isn't this a racist point and
he also vote it breaks it as well he was
like to see the thing you need to
understand Francis is that because of
freedom of trade from the EU
lots of people come over here and they
can do my job and I've got no problem
with that as people they're nice people
are work than they're decent nerds the
problem is is that then that means that
my rate of pay gets put down as a result
because there is more on competition so
by voting breaks it I am protecting
myself
economically and financially mmm and
when you hear someone put that argument
forward you go well fair enough because
that's what we do when we vote we just
we just vote for our own interests but
why is it that that is if this
working-class person does that that is
deemed to be racist yeah if you have the
other side of it that's acceptable um
sorry I'm a bit lost francis has that
affects people here mainly women mates
no I guess what he's saying is how come
is it it's okay for certain people to
vote in favor of the economic interests
yeah but not for others in the system
that we live in yeah I think you know
it's it's largely down to you know a
certain type of people are controlling
you know the chattering classes you
might say you know who are largely
controlling debate you know and how how
how opinions appear and what opinions
appear and obviously I mean
working-class voices I mean we know it
they barely exist in our public life now
which is actually a bit of a change from
I think back in the 60s and 70s when
they were coming more and more into
public life and now they're becoming
more and more marginalized so I think I
think it's partly that but you know and
that distancing obviously it kind of it
helps you know it helps us you know to
be about people you know if we kind of
all share the same sort of opinion we
don't know these people we don't sort of
respect their views I was going to ask
you in terms of the the left abandoning
working people it's like if I look at it
and I imagined that that's where I am
and I look at the political system now I
don't really see a party to vote for I
think a lot of a lot of the kind of
traditional old-school left people would
have voted for you Kipp at some point
hmm particularly while brexit hadn't
been achieved yet but now you're not
gonna vote for labour in the jeremy
corbyn you're probably not going to go
vote Tory you kippers in disarray so
where where do those people go
our current party system doesn't offer
anywhere no vote for people like that
and it's a very large bullier population
and let them I've seen from other people
you've interviewed that they've said you
know there's a big gap there and and if
anyone can plug that gap they can win
elections but but we can certainly see
none of the established parties have any
intention of filling that gap and I mean
it's one thing that I write in the book
that you know I mean my emotion is still
we know even after leaving labour and
criticizing it sort of extensively I
still have a love for labour and I still
like it to change and become more of a
meaningful party to do a greater body of
people but through writing the book and
rock you know and thinking a lot about
this sort of stuff I realize it was
version
impossible for it to do that because
it's become so immersed in the politics
of identity it's almost the first thing
that a lot of its people reach for we
see this in the public sphere
continually you know there are set
normally several identity politics
storms happening in our public sphere at
any one time and you can bet the labor
people and senior labor people Labour
MPs are going to be involved in that and
they're going to be fighting on one side
and I mean one thing that I did in the
book before the book was I looked into
the rulebook because I'd notice you know
being labor how politics of identity
preferential tea was all over just
internal labor processes from you know
how you selected who went to conference
- selecting candidates you know who
could serve a note you know a very local
ward committee you had to have to have a
certain amount of women you've got
offices which specifically represent
different identity groups and it's in
its these favorite identity was its
non-white and it's and it's women and
and some other groups so I mean I looked
into like I say the rule book and I
found I think in like 90 odd pages of it
that there were I think something like
250 300 mentions of of women women and
gender alone and it was maybe about a
third of that maybe a bit more for
ethnic related categories so 90 pages
you've got maybe three mentions on
average of this gender captain or gender
and gender related categories on every
page and this is how the party does its
internal business and activists have
been fighting to control the rule but
like this for years you know they've
been fighting for decades to achieve
this sort of thing and you can't just go
oh we're not ain't you're not into this
anymore because you know this stuff is
institutionalized into the party it's
worked into it and we're seeing this
more and more in the public sphere you
know the similar similar sort of stuff
that labor has done you know with
preferential atibaia by identity we're
seeing replicated in all sorts of
institutions you know national
institutions like the BBC are the media
organizations for example charities and
even businesses you know it's it's you
know almost labor right you know I've
written about as an institution of
diversity which provides a template for
this sort of preferential tea and the
more it gets worked into institutions
and is the basis on which they conduct
their internal affairs you know the less
easier it is to change it and we haven't
got any returning to your point about
political parties you know we haven't
got any political party which is you
know any major political party anyway
which is even at the threshold of
addressing the consequences of that and
whether that's also a good idea so this
what I was going to ask him before you
jump in what does it mean to be left
anymore because one of the big
criticisms that we get is we talk to a
lot of people who are kind of in your
position who who are coming from the
left but are frustrated about this
obsession with identity politics and
diversity and social justice and people
say to us well all you do is you just
get right-wing guests on and we're like
they're not right-wing they're just not
part of that so what where does that
leave someone like you how what what
what are your left is credentials what
makes you someone of the left still I
still consider the self here definitely
on the left and it's put it more comes
down to economics and redistribution you
could say class although I'm I'm a bit
reluctant to getting to these categories
of set categories you are this and there
especially since I think in one aspect
with a working class now which I think
it's quite interesting that literally as
a category it doesn't make sense anymore
you know the working class was formed
around organized labor and large-scale
industry which is now largely gone now
so it's it's more of an Inc existential
cattle
which you know is something that you
feel but it doesn't necessarily define
how how rich or poor you are so I mean I
think it's quite difficult to do that
but in terms of being left I mean I
still believe in redressing inequalities
January in in society and addressing the
dominance of the finance industry for
example the city of London here and you
know that sort of stuff is it's mostly
around economics and finance I'd say
well you know the sort of the the less
now social agenda a lot of it I find
very alienating because it is based
around identity the thing that I find
interesting when it comes to labour is
they don't seem as interested as in
winning elections which I find really
really bizarre all right after the last
general election the I was talking to
friends who are very progressive Leith
and voted Corbin and they were talking
about the last election like it was a
victory and I might I don't think you
understand you still lost when did when
did labour and are voted labour when did
we lose this this idea of wanting to win
an election well I think that's does the
change from you know the new labor
compact in the labour party to the core
then one no it's a it's a and you could
say maybe the Ed Miliband regime was a
kind of a crossover to that because new
labour it came to be know largely
defined by winning elections that was
the that was a large popular faith
although I mean looking back on it now
and you know this is something I
explored in the book of you know
starting to realize how ideological
labour was underneath it all but on the
surface they were they were very much
concerned with just winning elections
really and but that enables you to to
roll out your programs you know and
stuff which isn't necessarily in your
manifesto so I think yeah that changed
to first ed Miliband and then the far
left you know that they've been that
that sort of that side of the Labour
Party's been out of power
basically forever you know they're not
used to it and so they so so they're
sort of sense of being it's not it's not
so attached what they value is not so
attached with actually having power you
know so I'd say it's more it's more
about familiarity as much as anything
isn't that the point of a political
party to get I know to get into power or
am I just losing sight of it you want to
you want to impose it your program so I
mean there's compromises to be made you
know how how much are you sort of purist
about your program what you want to do
if you got into power and then how much
are you prepared to actually sort of
address the electorate as a group I mean
that's a that's a Silla balancing act
really that's it and the thing that I
find particularly interesting when it
comes we talk about the hierarchies of
privilege the the number one the apex
for the hierarchy of privilege seems to
be old white men which to me seems
incredibly ages because a lot of old
people in this country quite frankly are
struggling economically financially you
know like we were saying earlier about
sort of facts and reality isn't really
what this is all about and you know it's
ideological and I think devote an
interesting aspect with older people is
that they appear as being regressive and
backward and and for example I mean you
could say there is some reason for for
saying that you know for example that
racist may be sexist attitudes in a
certain sense are more common amongst
you know older people of previous
generations but that that's more of an
excuse I think to sort of bash them but
I think it's this is where progressive
you know the progressive element of
politics comes in because progressive
politics is really about it's about
things improving over time getting
better over time
and it's a faith that that's happening
so in that sense people who are around
you know in previous times are naturally
sort of worse and more regressive than
you know young people is that for
example so if you find sort of
progressive politicians they tend to
exalt the younger and then dismissed the
older which I mean I agree with you I
think that's a really bad way of you
know addressing especially from a left
solidarity in society you know of
dismissing people who have been on this
earth for a lot longer than we have have
a lot more experience and just
dismissing of them as if they have
nothing valuable to offer I think that's
that's a terrible approach and I think
there should be like a cutoff point for
like white privilege once you get to
like a seventy you've got some kind of
wasting disease it takes away your
privileges and you just yeah exactly
thank you for taking that joke into a
very very dark place because when people
criticize Trump a number of times when
what I saw from people is I what do you
expect he's an old white man the moment
when he said my mom's Venezuela
Venezuelan go into America but it just
seems such a bizarre thing to accuse
somebody of you know it's saying he's
older he's an old white male therefore
he has these views it comes back to it's
just so easy isn't it yeah and you know
this again what I'm talking about with
social system of diversity it's like you
can say that so if you said that on
Twitter you know you see people saying
that on Twitter they'll get thousands
and retweets
you just make these lazy remarks it's an
effective form of politics you know it's
so easy we can all grab hold of it and
there you go guys if you want to be a
social media influence say you know what
to do yeah you know where to take it you
got fat shame to hell as well
it's perfectly respectable to fat shame
Donald Trump
although he does fat shame other
people's own medicine
but don't years got fat ass to be honest
how do you know
I've seen pictures of it okay nice to
know what kind of porn you watch anyway
anyway we're getting towards the end of
I interview and one of the things that
we wanted to talk to you about it you
talk about a couple of things which I
think are really important and let's get
to both of them before we ask our very
final question first of all you talked
about the false power of prediction
people talking about how this is what's
going to happen and then this is what's
going to happen if we don't do that then
this is gonna happen and eventually none
of it happens and we all keep going as
if if this those predictions hadn't been
made you know and that person didn't
lose any credibility we just keep
predicting stuff that never happens
hmm and then just carry on as if
everything is the same
to talk to us about that bit well I
think is a it comes down to know the
authority that appears from knowledge
and you know obviously there's a there's
a good reason for you know but obviously
it depends on if the knowledge is
actually real or not now the thing with
predictions is you know by definition
the truth is not verified you know you
can't tell what's going to happen before
it but predictions appear as if they are
truthful you know especially if they
come from someone you know who is
authoritative you know who works for say
the banking and you know a big
organization big international
organization you know anyone who
produces reports so basically anyone
who's you know sort of organized and
they they can produce something which
appears our ferocity and you can make
predictions and and that appears as a
form of knowledge but it's obviously
it's it's obviously sort of well well
you you know like I said before you
can't verify either way so that
predictions kind of appear in the public
sphere
as authoritative
and there's no way to to demonstrate
that until whatever they predicted
either happens or doesn't and of course
by the time that happens the whole the
whole circus has moved on so you can
even predict another thing and with the
same level of authority yeah as long as
you have the position and the ability to
you know contact the media and they will
you know the authoritative 'ti from the
media to get your stuff out there you
can keep on you know replaying and it
doesn't really matter I mean some people
are obviously going to pick you up on it
but most people out there and not really
paying attention do you realize what
you've just done is given a blueprint to
how to become a guardian journal I mean
it's interesting you know because it
does seem to be that you can make these
you know these grandiose predictions and
everybody discusses it and then next
week and really isn't the only point of
a prediction so that you can end up with
four words told I told you so I mean
that's essentially it isn't it and then
people go back to it and then go look I
mean that that would be the you know the
you know approach which follows you know
the the disciplines of theory and
knowledge and checking and falsifying
and and and then you know looking to
revise if theories and all the rest of
it but politics isn't like that you know
it's it's it's more about authority and
getting your thing out there yeah it's
it's not I told you so it's it's about
what you're telling people is going to
happen yeah and then that allows you to
control what happens in the present
right yes it's a mouth shaping the
message today so the different decisions
get made because you've predicted
something yeah yeah exactly another
final point I want to ask you about as
well is you talk about you know one of
my one of the we have very big fans of
Dave Rubin and his show and he talks a
lot about the power of good ideas over
bad ideas which is something that I you
know I share as well I think ideas are
very important discussing them is very
important which is one of the reasons
that we do the show but one of the
things you mention
in the book and you make quite quite
clear is that this ideology that we're
talking about the ideology of social
justice of diversity and whatever you
will not be defeated through ideas
because they're not fighting that
cultural war through ideas they're
fighting it through institutions which
they've seized control over right so
what is the answer man you've got about
30 seconds to come up with a blueprint
for how we solve this crisis of Western
civilization go well I don't think there
isn't a silver bullet
I was joking I know there's no sort of
well I I think it's it's it's basically
about all of us who are concerned and
give a [ __ ] that we we do get active and
we organize and we contact each other
and we form institutions and to do that
you need money and you need people
prefer two billion hard work and you
know this this takes time means like I
say with with the book you know sort of
exploring this idea of a system of
diversity no I didn't use that word by
mistake it's you know it's systemic in a
sense but you can you can break out of
it but you're taking a risk when you do
everyone is taking a risk and to make to
make any sort of politics which is we're
drawing away from that or criticizing
that well preserving are the elements
which are good hopefully has got a you
know be organized in and rigorous and
well financed so I mean this this isn't
easy we don't do it just by sitting and
pontificating like we do yeah well I
think the been made of a very eloquent
point there that we need money you know
what I'm talking about anyway give them
money yeah exactly
yeah and we'll be plugging your book in
a second but final question Frances
right so this is how we always like to
end our interviews Ben so what is the
important thing that we are not talking
about at the moment as a society but
actually we really
well it's something I mean I'd I would
say that I've you know I find it
uncomfortable to talk about myself and
and that talking the more we do talk
about it the more uncomfortable things
do get but it's you know which is I mean
I think a lot of our you know our public
sphere they really do
I mean want to sort of put it away know
that it doesn't really exist out there
but it's you know as I as I found sort
of exploring the themes of the book it's
very it's a very powerful form politics
it's it's very linked in to the left and
the liberal left and even beyond that
and you know it's very organized I mean
that's the characteristic of it so I
think just being honest and I mean as I
like to think I do in the book just
described to have more description of
what's going on in that in that sort of
world in our public sphere would be very
valuable I think fantastic listen before
we let you go tell everybody your
Twitter handle is so it's been probably
I'm in Copley being CEO be any water
effect we'll put that in in the YouTube
videos we always do get this book it's
fantastic both Francis and I have read
it we really enjoyed it you know it's a
good book when Francis has read it yeah
absolutely doesn't happen very often and
yeah check out Ben's work you've got a
blog as well if you want to tell us
about that yeah that's called a free
left blog I don't write so much for it
now but there's there's over I think
about 150 articles on there a lot of
them about identity politics fantastic
so check all of that out and of course
we are at trigger pod on Twitter on
Instagram on Facebook as I mentioned at
the beginning of the video we're going
to be moving away from patreon over time
we're still there for now but we've got
subscribed start and PayPal which is how
you can support us making this show is
anything else we need to mention yes if
you like the show could you please leave
this semester you up to 29 reviews on on
iTunes so pathetic
there's nothing wrong with rubbish look
I find this hate speech disgusting and
somebody who is half Latin American
you're all oppressing me [ __ ] you but no
please leave us a message on itunes if
you like it why don't you tell somebody
about it retweet spread the word
subscribe just keep telling people about
it maybe not a work because it will get
you fired but maybe just you know in
your own personal life though not on
whatsapp because you're all getting
tracked anyway
so there we go alright and remember
subscribe to us obviously on YouTube and
click that Bell button next to subscribe
button to make sure you get every
episode sent straight to you so that you
know what we've got coming if you are a
subscriber Weiser will be putting loads
of stuff out on patreon and subscribe
Stine else wait to let you know what's
going on going on we've got some
absolutely fantastic gets just like
today's coming over the next month or so
so keep an eye out and keep supporting
us and we will see you in a weeks in a
week's time thanks a lot see you later
guys bye
[Music]